- L'enseignante Vickie Vachon
ne décolère pas depuis
son retour au Québec.
Lors de son voyage à Cayo Coco
avec des amis, elle aurait
rencontré un ingénieur prénommé
Simon au bar de l'hôtel
le 3 juillet.
VICKIE VACHON
- En marchant, Simon m'a pris
la fesse d'une façon...
très, très... très intense,
très agressive, une très grosse
poignée de fesse.
Et évidemment, je me suis
fâchée. Je lui ai hurlé dessus.
Je lui ai donné un bon coup
de pied sur les tibias.
Et là, il disait :"Je suis déso,
c'est mes mains! C'est pas moi,
c'est mes mains, c'est
mes mains!"
- C'est - C'est - C'est à son rs
les Laurentides que Vickie
Vachon aurait vu Simon Houle
dans les médias et l'aurait
immédiatement reconnu.
- J'ai eu un choc. J'ai...
Ça m'a troublée au plus haut
point.
- Un autre touriste,
qui ne voyageait pas avec elle,
affirme aussi avoir identifié
l'ingénieur.
- Vickie Vachon dénonce
l'absolution conditionnelle
dont a bénéficié Simon Houle,
notamment en raison
de sa carrière et
de sa bonne moralité.
Dans un posé
à la cour dont Radio-Canada
a obtenu copie, son agent
de probation soulignait
son insécurité avec les femmes
et une certaine peur du rejet.
- Si ce gars-là avait été
un mécanicien, bien, il l'aurait
eu, son casier judiciaire.
Mais non, lui, il est ingéniest,
avec sa belle bague, puis
il a le droit d'être là.
- Elle a porté plainte à police.
Mais comme les gestes auraient
été posés à l'étranger,
pour porter des accusations,
le DPCP devrait procéder à
une analyse juridique, laquellee
de l'ensemble des circonstances.
Si la preuve est suffisante,
Simon Houle pourrait aussi être
accusé de ne pas avoir respecté
les conditions de sa probation,
comme avoir une bonne conduite.
CHARLES CÔTÉ,
avocat-ce
- Le ministère public pourrait
demander à ce que le dossier
soit renvoyé devant le juge
Poliquin et qu'il rende
la sentence appropriée.
- (en choeur): Envoie Simon
en prison!
- Ces nouvelles allégations
galvanisent des activistes
qui ont manifesté contre
le jugem réclament
plus d'encadrement pour éviter
les récidives.
MÉLANIE LEMAY, cofondatrice,
Québec contre les violences sex.
- Il y a un rôle à jouer
par rapport à comment
on peut faciliter l'accès à
ces thérapies-là, parce que,
ent, j'ai beaucoup
de misère à m'imaginer
que ce genre de situation-là
n'est qu'un cas isolé.
- Vickie Vachon pense aux de
victimes connues de Simon Houle,
dont celle pour laquelle
il n'a jamais été accusé.
- Je veux que les juges
y repensent à deux fois avant de
laisser en liberté un agresseur!
- Ici Geneviève Garon,
Radio-Canada, Mo